all right man I'm Dean Norris I'm here
to answer the Internet and meanwhile
I'll go to crash a comment by some
Schrader Brown who wins in a fight
ten ten year olds or 101 I'm going with
the ten ten year olds yeah yeah yeah
just because the yeah just because the
you know I 100 man you're not you know
you're not doing that would you rather
be a leg or never have lose a leg
I'll take lose the [ __ ] leg
would you rather fart popcorn or a
sneeze butter I think I would
I think I'd fart popcorn cuz that's a
great [ __ ] Bartha right [ __ ] you you
know say yeah I would not heat is eat it
no that's what I had the night before
what is the fiercest animal you think
you could take in the fight mmm not many
man animals are badasses I was in my tan
of this yeah I mean a small dog you know
that's something if I could kick it
first but I don't mean I don't mean that
bad I'm saying he was attacking me if
you could upgrade one body part bicep
would you rather have unlimited beer for
the rest of your life I'll be able to
give anybody the Stone Cold Stunner
I don't know so close so whenever you
want with zero weight cold stones yeah
I'll have a beer the rest of my life
would you rather be stuck in gym on
yours Jurassic Park yeah for sure yeah
okay would you rather always wear high
heels
I'm going with the belly shirt because
you know I got a billion [ __ ] if you
could bring back one person from the
dead who that's like that's a sad one
that's like a sad I'll be my dad back
then a pigs car wow man what the [ __ ] is
wrong with the Internet a pigs orgasm
lasts for over 30 minutes a lion can
have sex over 50 times per day which
would you rather be I'd go with the 50
times cuz 30 30 minutes he'd just be I
mean you know I'm saying like smoking a
cigarette around orgasm still a [ __ ]
it's still going
would you rather only watch softcore
porn [ __ ] that's softcore porn
[Laughter]